quelques minutes sous le feu a ravagé le
café mancini il était environ 7h30 ce
matin quand un incendie s'est déclaré
sur cette place les josé rivera était
dans son bar il ne s'est pas rendu
compte des premières flammes avant
d'être alertés par l'odeur là où ça a
pris il y avait des cartons il y avait
des choses entre pose est donc pris là
c'est vite oui mais au départ j'ai pas
eu le réflexe de penser que ça brûlait
donc
je m'en suis aperçu quand il y avait des
flammes j'ai pas pu éteindre une
vingtaine de pompiers rapidement
intervenus dans le centre historique de
nevers l'important était d'éviter la
propagation de l'incendié aux bâtiments
voisins
nous avons des bâtiments qui sont très
anciens et assez imbriquée avec des
planchers bois question des vieilles
structures qui font que à tout moment
par une interstices on peut avoir un feu
qui qui se propage d'un étage à l'autre
sachant qu'on adule stockage beaucoup de
stockage l étage si le feu par se
développa laitages après ça va être plus
compliqué à atteindre les étages
supérieurs étaient heureusement
inoccupée mais une dizaine de personnes
a dû être évacué
aucun blessé n'est à déplorer d'après
les premières constatations c'est de
l'extérieur du café que serait parti le
sinistre
visiblement encore une fois c'est un feu
de poubelle comme dans 80 % des
incendies qui sont traités par les
pompiers qui sont souvent les feux de
poubelles ils ne sont pas isolés
et donc qui provoque des dégâts très
importants et ce très rapidement
l'incendié a pu être maîtrisé mais
l'intérieur de l'établissement est
intégralement détruit le propriétaire
artiste peintre a également perdu près
de 300 tableaux dans le sinistre